[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a south korean comedy drama
film called mr zoo the missing vip
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
tai zhu is an obsessive perfectionist he
likes to live a routine life eating
exactly 135 calories for breakfast
keeping everything around the house in
its designated place and picking up tiny
loose threads from his clothes to make
them perfect he doesn't realize he has
an obsession because it has gotten him
far in life especially in his work he
currently works as an agent in korea's
biggest security firm top national
security widely known as nis
one thing about taiji is that he
despises animals of all kinds one day in
an elevator he comes across a man and
his pet pug taiju calls the animal a
punk and makes faces at it when its
owner isn't looking then his worst
nightmare comes true when the dog pees
on him the owner rubs it all over
taiju's face while apologizing at work
he practices shooting a little more
aggressively that day his mood gets
better only when his colleagues
congratulate him in advance for a
promotion that he is about to get then
everyone is called to a meeting to
discuss their next big project they have
to escort a vip from china to an event
and ensure her safety the event is
organized to celebrate 25 years of
diplomatic relationship between china
and korea the vip has been sent to korea
as a sign of peace and is crucial for
diplomatic relations between the two
countries it turns out that the said vip
is a panda from china named ming ming
the director asks if anyone wants to
volunteer to be the chief of security
for the event although taiji hates
animals this opportunity might secure
his promotion so he smugly agrees to do
it on the day of the event everyone is
excited about ming ming's arrival taijo
keeps the event premises in check and
makes sure everything is secure several
military dogs have also been brought to
ensure absolute safety taiju meets his
junior agent cronie who has just
returned from a trip to new zealand
hoping to impress taiju cronie shows him
a pen that temporarily stops all
electronic devices within a hundred mile
radius crony has good intentions but he
always screws up because of his luck
hence taijo asks him to stay where he is
and not interfere in anything the
program finally begins and ming ming
comes out in public while everyone
cheers and takes pictures but trouble
arises when a group of thugs arrives at
the venue with smoke bombs and
tranquilizers they throw the bombs to
the stage making everyone run away ming
ming also panics and runs around crony
sees this and gets on a cart to follow
her taiju also runs behind her but has
to stop when the thugs hit ming ming
with the tranquilizer gun he tries to
stop them but they use another smoke
bomb to get her inside the van and
escape taiju is about to follow them but
just then crony hits him with his cart
proving that his existence brings
trouble taiji flies in the air and falls
down hitting his head on the concrete
before passing out he sees a guard dog
running towards him the dog asks him why
he is sleeping in such a serious
situation and follows the van when taiju
wakes up he finds himself in his house
with a cervical collar it turns out that
the event from yesterday was declared a
trap organized by nis to ensure nothing
like that would happen in the real event
this was done to hide ming ming's
kidnapping from the media taiji gets on
the elevator to go to work where he
again meets the pug from yesterday this
time he can hear the dog talking to
himself saying that he wants to pee on
taiju's face again he freaks out
thinking that he might be going crazy
the dog then begs him to be his
interpreter and requests his owner to
not castrate him taiji runs directly to
the supermarket to buy healthy food and
medicine thinking that he is sick in the
pet section of the store a hamster begs
taiju to take him home and even offers a
discount
following that a hedgehog boasts about
its spines trying to compete against the
hamster as they argue about who is the
better pet taiju runs away he goes to
work and hears the fishes in the tank
laughing at him they find it funny that
he was hoping for a promotion until
yesterday and now he is about to be
fired taiju asks his director if he is
being removed from service she claims
that he is one of the best agents so
losing him would be a huge loss for the
company the fishes then talk about an
employee dropping boogers into the tank
they make a lot of noise irritating
taiju who breaks down into a scream when
all the employees look at him in
confusion he tells the director that he
can talk to animals thinking that he
isn't in his right mind she asks him to
take a rest for a few days after that
taiji goes to the zoo where the fake
ming ming is being kept in reality the
panda is crony in a costume who has been
put there so that people won't suspect
the real one has been kidnapped as tai
zhu and cronie chat in the back room
crony accidentally lights his costume on
fire and has to be taken to the hospital
while returning home taiji is called by
a female gorilla she claims to know
where he can find the vip panda but asks
for a magazine in return for the
information taiju brings her a magazine
published by national geographic she
fangirls over the pictures of celebrity
gorillas in the magazine then she
informs taiji of a dog named ali who
jumped over him when he fell unconscious
yesterday that dog followed the
kidnappers and still recognizes their
scent if taiji can find the dog he can
be led to the kidnappers that evening he
goes to an abandoned house where the dog
is bragging about his bravery to a group
of animals the animals listen in awe as
he explains how he saved a group of
soldiers in serbia when taiji comes into
their view they attack him for being a
human he throws sausages to them and
manages to distract everyone following
that he catches ali and runs away with
him on the car ride back home he asks
the dog about the panda kidnappers but
ali refuses to reveal anything he takes
advantage of the opportunity and asks
for unlimited food the two come to
taiju's spotless apartment ali runs
around the place as taiju sweeps the
path that he walks on the next morning
taiji wakes up and almost doesn't
recognize his apartment because it has
been thoroughly trashed by the dog as
ali is being scolded taiji's daughter
sio yan arrives with two of her friends
xio yan's mother died a long time ago
after which her and taiju's relationship
hasn't been the same they do not live
together because of taiji's job so he
had invited her to the house promising
to throw her a birthday party however on
seeing the house trashed she realizes
that her father forgot her birthday yet
again as taiju apologizes ali catches
sioyan's attention she is happy that her
father finally got over his irrational
fear of animals and adopted a dog taiju
doesn't want to hurt her so he doesn't
tell her the truth then they go to the
park and enjoy the day playing with the
dog in the evening before she leaves
taiji tries to hug her but the little
girl stops him and initiates a fist bump
the fireworks nearby remind ali of his
time in serbia and he gets anxious on
being asked he says that he remembers
the scent of the person who kidnapped
ming ming it was the same person who
killed his master in serbia a flashback
shows us that ali was a shy dog until
his master sue he came along she was the
only person he got along with but one
day when they were in the enemy's
territory an explosion killed her ali
tried to attack the person who set off
the explosive and found out that he had
a prosthetic leg yet he couldn't stop
the man that day when ming ming was
kidnapped he smelled the man's scent
again and recognized him after learning
of his story taiji feels bad for the dog
ali chases him playfully asking him to
smell his butt like a dog somewhere else
in a warehouse ming ming asks to only
eat exclusive bamboo and not the cheap
twigs so the kidnappers get her bamboo
from a farm the following day ali leads
taiji to a bamboo farm where he smells
the scent of the kidnapper they ask the
bamboo seller's pet goat and find the
kidnapper's license plate number after
further research they come across the
founder of a successful biotech company
man seek on seeing his picture ali
instantly recognizes him as ming ming's
kidnapper taiji is skeptical but he
trusts ali's instincts they go to the
company's headquarters and find out that
man seek is about to launch a new
project he plans to create a toy panda
by cloning the genes of a real panda
they will be like a new species that
people can keep as a pet since the
chinese government holds exclusive
rights to pandas all around the world he
has stolen ming ming to use her genes
taiju attacks man seek and his
bodyguards and manages to arrest him he
quickly drives the criminal to the nis
headquarters accidentally leaving ali
behind nis's director asks him what
proof he has about man seeks involvement
in the kidnapping but taiji has no
answers they find out that manseq was in
new york when the kidnapping took place
because of the false accusation taiji is
fired from his job after being let off
manseq goes directly to the people he
hired to kidnap ming ming it is revealed
that a terrorist named dimitri was the
one who kidnapped ming ming ali got
confused because dimitri was wearing a
realistic mask to look like man seek in
turn for dimitri's service he asks man
seek for explosive capsules the capsule
when fed to a human or an animal will
activate a timer and explode ali who has
been following man's seek until now
hears all of this and finds out the
truth he also meets ming ming and
promises to rescue her he then runs back
to taiji's house and rings the doorbell
but taiji doesn't open the door he no
longer trusts the dog since he lost his
job because of him the people from the
military take the dog away to put him
down when xio yon returns from looking
for ali she finds out that her father
abandoned him seeing that she is sad and
disappointed in him taiji decides to
save ali's life he goes to the military
dog shelter and rescues him the dog is
overjoyed to be saved until taiju
mentions that he hates him he asks ali
to go away but the dog is persistent at
last he mentions that he saw ming ming
and brings taiji to the warehouse in the
hills coincidentally they happened to
meet crony who got lost during a hike
taiji knows his presence means bad luck
so he asks him to stay outside after
that ali and tai zhu carefully sneak
into the warehouse using an electric gun
they managed to kill almost all of the
terrorists demetri and taiju get into a
fight taiji is about to get killed but
ali saves him and the two run away with
the panda they climb up the hill and
roll several barrels down so the thugs
cannot follow them along with one of the
barrels crony also falls down the other
three run the entire night and reach a
highway being the diva she is ming ming
asks for a limo because she cannot lose
more weight later they get on a bus
pretending that ming ming is a human in
a panda costume upon reaching home taiju
calls his daughter and introduces her to
ming ming they play together for a long
time back in the warehouse man seek is
frustrated because of ming ming's
disappearance when he belittles dimitri
the terrorists make him eat the
explosive pill and lock him inside a
room it turns out that dimitri's
original plan was to feed the panda the
pill and hand it back to the zoo she was
about to be present at an event where
leaders of china and korea met using the
pill he wanted to blow up the place
along with the leaders when the
terrorist group is outside the house
explodes indicating that the pill that
was fed to man seek worked back in the
house taiji calls the director and
introduces her to ming ming his house is
also filled with all the animals he has
talked to by now they finally call a
limo for ming ming and send her to the
venue where the leaders are meeting
while seeing her off ali smells a weird
scent and follows it he is kidnapped by
dimitri's people again taiji and his
daughter see them taking him away but
cannot stop them in time taiji returns
home and asks the parrot to find ali the
parrot in turn tells all the birds in
the city and starts looking for the dog
meanwhile dimitri forcefully makes ali
and other military dogs eat the
explosive capsule since they will also
be in the venue dimitri wants to use
them to cause the explosion the program
finally begins and the world leaders
meet each other when it is ming ming's
time to perform dmitry starts the
countdown through his phone the dogs are
let out making everyone panic since the
doors are locked from outside the
audience doesn't get to run away with
only a few seconds left on the clock
taiji runs to crony and uses his special
pen the signal freezes all electronic
devices including dimitri's phone which
means the explosives are diffused
dimitri tries to run away but is chased
by ali they get to the rooftop and fight
each other in the process ali is
severely injured dimitri is about to
shoot the dog when taiju saves his life
but gets shot himself in the process in
the next scene taiji wakes up in a
hospital bed he finds out that ali is
also at a vet and is not doing well he
rushes to meet the dog and finds him
dead on the table he and sio yan cry
mourning his death however a while later
the vet says that ali is just sleeping
the ending scene shows us ali receiving
a medal for his bravery from the
director subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching